último adiós de Rusia a mijael gorbachov
rodeado de sus seres queridos Y de miles
de Seguidores el último líder de la
antigua Unión soviética fue enterrado en
Moscú tras morir a los 91 años
creo que esta persona se merecía una
ceremonia de despedida verdaderamente
popular es una persona histórica
independientemente de lo que piensen
algunos hizo mucho aunque algunos
piensan que hizo más mal que bien yo
creo que hizo más bien
Y es que el político reformista lidera
el final de la guerra fría y marcó la
perturismo de Rusia al mundo en los 90
lo que finalmente acabó con la unión
soviética fue enterrado sin la
característica ceremonia de estado de
sus predecesores y sin retransmisión en
directo de la televisión Estatal además
de contar con una gran Ausencia la del
presidente Vladimir Putin que se limitó
a llevarle un ramo de rosas tras
conocerse su muerte el martes
debemos apreciar las cosas buenas que
gorbachov hizo por nosotros contribuyó
mucho al desarrollo de los medios de
comunicación de la sociedad civil y en
general apoyó a nuestro país en el
ámbito internacional
cientos de rusos hicieron fila frente a
la famosa casa de los sindicatos de
Moscú donde se celebró la ceremonia de
despedida de gorbachov quien construida
remarca el fin de una era en Rusia ahora
en medio de una nueva guerra